ότι έπρεπε να κλείσει ένα κύπεδον για να μπορέσουμε να το αναβαθμήσουμε να τον ανακινήσουμε
ξεκίνησε εί η συζήτηση περιήτων υποδομόνοι οποίες αυτή τη στιγμή είναι υπάρχουν κάποιες αλλά είναι
παλαιωμένες και χρειάζονται ρι ζδικής ανακίνησης ή ανεβάθμησης και χειρόμαστε που είμασταν αυτοή πουβάλαμε αυτ
ου ανοίξαμε α αυτή τη συζήτηση που βάλαμε στην ακέντα το θέματων των κυπέδον τον
κυπειδικών εν καταστάσειων και το αθελη τηκουρισμού του υρισμού και χειρόμαστε που οι κυβέρνηση και
ο πρόεδρος τελευταίο μήνα έει εξαγγύλει και έχει κάνει διάφορες το ποθητήσεις που αφορούν αναβαθμίσεις
και άλλον κυπέδον όπως είναι παραδιμοοσχάρι τω οι έθους αγλάφος κληρίσες των αγρόν και η
δημιουργεία νέων κυπέδων όπως είναι στην κυπερούνταν καις ε άλλους χορούς οι οποίες οη κυβερνησεί
θαανακιτώ να αποκτήσουμε να γίνουν κάποιε αίθουσες καλαθώσφερας ευρωπαϊκό προδιαγραφον οι οποίες θα είναι κάτι
καινούργιο αφού θέλουμε να αναλαμβάνουμε αυτά είναι στον ωρίζοντα είναι στα πλάνα σας εξτατικά μας
τα πλά ός όμος πονδίανα ζητήσετε σουμε να γ να γίνεινα ητάδι όπως έχουμε το
τάσος πααδόπουλος ελευθερεία να γίνει κάτι πιο σύχρο καιταξετα οι όμως πονίδες δεν μπορούν από
μόνες τους ν να να κατασκεβάσουν οη α αναβαθμήσουν οή ανακινησου κή πεταχρειάζεται όπως δήποτε
συ πολιτική βούληση και ηη πολιτική από την κυβέρνηση οι συγκεκριαυτή η κυβέρνηση έχει έχει
εξαγγίλει διάφορα τέτοια πλάνα οπωο πρόεδρος τις δημοκρατές πρόέκομενες ημέρες όταν πάροσ όταν πήγαινε στην
εκδήλωση του του γάσειό αναφέρθηκε για το θέμα του τσιρίου και ναφέρθηκε και στην εκπόνηση
μιας φιλόδοξης τσι στρατηγικής αναβάθημησης και ανακαίνησης και δημιουργείας και άλλον χώρον που έχουν να
κάνουν με αίθουσες κλειστές έθωσες για όλα τα θλήματα αλλά ακόμα και την εξαγγυλία του
για πάρολημπιακόν και έντρον το οποίον είναι κάτι τοπος